[Musique]
on se trouve à 7 m sous terre dans un
dans les locaux qui accueillaient un
accélérateur de particules qui a été
construit à la fin des années 60 qui
était désaffecté et qui constitue un
terrain d'accueil extraordinaire pour le
laser àollon pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que la dalle possède une
une stabilité absolument incroyable elle
fait 2 m d'épaisseur et donc elle permet
au faisceau laser de se propager sur des
centaines de mètres tout en conservant
une précision de pointer de l'ordre du
micron dans les salles
expérimentales l'autre aspect c'est que
elle offre une radioprotection
extrêmement lourde des murs de 4 M80
d'épaisseur absolument partout sur
l'installation ce qui était vraiment
intéressant pour nous puisque ce laser
va servir en quelque sorte de
d'accélérateur de particules
miniature on se trouve ici dans une
salle expérimentale qui va accueillir le
laser Apollon et ici le faisceau laser
qui fait typiquement 40 cm de diamètre
va être concentré jusqu'à des dimensions
qui sont équivalente à la taille d'un
cheveux voire inférieur pour atteindre
des des éclairements extraordinairees
qui sont plus d'un million de milliards
de fois supérieurs à celui qui règne à
la surface du Soleil dans ces condition
on étudie ici on va étudier comment la
matière réagit lorsqu'elle est illuminée
de façon aussi
intense Apollon pour moi est à la fois
un projet phare de l'Université Paris
saclé mais mais aussi un symbole de
l'Université Paris Saclay parce qu'il
réunit dès le départ 11 laboratoires du
plateau de saay euh avec un ensemble de
tutell assez large euh et qui est
soutenu par un un grand nombre de de
financements à la fois locaux nationaux
et européens l'objectif étant à la fois
de de construire une nouvelle
installation euh à à l'usage d'une large
communauté et aussi de développer des
des thèmes de recherche vraiment à la
pointe des connaissances
actuelles depuis le printemps le laser
est en cours de
dans les salles dédié au laser cette
construction va se poursuivre dans
l'année qui vient et les premiers tirs
laser sont attendus pour 2017 date à
laquelle l'installation commencera à
accueillir des chercheurs du monde
[Musique]
entier